I told y'all last week he was coming for
heads he was coming for necks and you
still continue to see it CJ stra is
dominating NFL he is making it look so
easy like he is 41 against teams with a
winning record he has beat the
Jacksonville Jack and Wars he's beat the
Steelers he just
beat the Bengals teams that you would
think is so dominant so dominant like I
think like we are we cannot confuse this
CJ stra is a top 10 quarterback in the
NFL right now he is he should be in a
conversation for MVP he might just win
it all be the second player ever to win
offensive rookie and uh MVP in the same
season he's playing that Elite level he
has guys like Noah Brown Noah was a
great player for us and he's balling
Houston Noah Brown second game over 100
yards in a row uh tank D was playing at
a really Elite level Dalton SCH is
playing at a really Elite level he is
making the players around him so much
better CJ Stout is he cemented himself
it's not even a like it shouldn't even
be a conversation he is an MVP caliber
right now he is playing the best
football and he's doing with less he's
playing at a Patrick Mahomes level if
not right below people do not realize
that that he is making a statement right
now um and and I seen a lot of
conversation with people bashing uh uh
Bryce young cuz he's one in8 and do they
regret not taking Cesar stoud the
Panthers absolutely not and this is why
I hate this because we love to just
throw people in the dirt when they're
down let Bryce young develop I think CJ
stra may have went into a little bit
better
situation um there there there's not a
lot in Carolina right now you know you a
lot of people said about their offensive
creativity um I don't think they're
using to him strength Bryce young uh
their offens line hasn't been the best
uh you can say the running game hasn't
been the best uh the receivers hasn't
really been the best um so there's a lot
more at hand that Bryce has to deal with
so there there's that so I don't think
we should just throw away Bryce just yet
I think we should let him get a couple
years give him that same Grace as we did
everybody else and what I will always
keep saying um and and you know I think
it's truly not fair even guys like
Trevor Lawrence who struggled their
first year look how well he's doing um
now that he has Calvin really uh Z Jones
they wouldn't uh they wouldn't had Evan
Ingram he grew he grew uh it just takes
times you got to build a team that that
supports him and around him um I think
he's very good you seen in his tape he
can make those Elite passes he can do
that but it comes down to coaching it
comes down to Talent around give him
time let him break out I think Bryce
young will have his breakout year it's
just not this year it will be in the up
years but he still be
good